et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis houston avait que joe dougherty
soutien de donald trump c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur
[Musique]
joe dougherty merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors bien
qu'ils soient en retard de près de 1 9
point
le président américain a team toujours
une chance de gagner à l'élection
américaine pew une double choeur de
lumière en 2016
les sondages nous et qu'il arrête une
passe dans les canaux pour remporter la
victoire pour plus de 300 grands
électeurs sont montés très tard dans la
soirée de la journée d'élection qu'on a
réalisé que hillary clinton ne pas qu'à
lieu effectivement il encore de bonnes
chances car l'histoire l'a montré les
sondages on tarde alors donald trump
tente de conserver plusieurs étapes
majeures dans la course à la
présidentielle
la floride l'ohio la géorgie ainsi que
l'agoa est ce qu'il peut y parvenir et
comment on avait évoqué outre au 4 mai
au total d'un même heure ils passent
beaucoup de temps dans son lit quand il
le ciem tout le pays
si l on regarde les meetings de
l'empreinte des milliers de personnes se
rendent sur place avec enthousiasme
attendent parfois quatre cinq voire 15
heures à faire la queue s'agissant des
meetings de joe biden
on voit quelques centaines de personnes
et il est très difficile de savoir ce
qui se passe je pense donc que donnant
30 à bien plus d'élan les peuples
derrière lui et il fera ce qu'il faut
pour a remporté ses états clés alors on
note par ailleurs une très forte
participation avec elle les votes par
correspondance à qui cela profite il
il faut regarder les états stratégiques
car en cette période ce qui est
important soixante deux millions de
personnes sont enregistrés sur les
listes électorales de ces 9 août à
environ 9 millions de votes ont été
enregistrés et on dit que la plupart a
été fait déjà enregistré tête en faveur
des démocrates
les nombreux et des votes des votes
anticipés les sondages cela ne fait pas
de grande différence
ce qui est important c'est ce qu'il va
se passer
il y a dans quinze jours leweb 10
novembre lorsque les gens vont réagir
donald trump
alors pour le dernier débat prévue le 22
octobre
à quoi est ce qu'on peut s'attendre
entre les deux candidats côté télé
l'équipe de notre je pense qu'on
évoquera les succès de donald trump mot
taux de chômage le plus bas de
l'histoire
les plus importantes baisses d'impôts la
paix au moyen orient
voilà le programme de donald trump
voici les succès de donald trump ce sont
des faits
quant à ce que joe biden a évoqué une
pourrait évoquer le manque de réactivité
face à la paix vide ou pourrait en faire
un sujet majeur
on pourrait parler du changement
climatique s'ils sont les sujets
démocrate habituels comme par exemple
les divisions raciales
ce sont des choses qu'il ment sur le
tapis dans ce livre aucun autre sujet a
évoqué
a passé de très longues années au
gouvernement et il n'y a rien à montrer
pour cela il ne peut pas mettre en avant
des succès même si on lui demande
régulièrement carrément m'a pas à son
son tableau donald trump est président
depuis moins de quatre ans et il a déjà
beaucoup de succès dont il va parler
bien sûr
alors on entend des voix dans le camp
républicain qui s'élèvent contre donald
trump est ce que cela peut lui porter
préjudice
nokia ne suis pas il faut regarder qui
s'exprime là à ce mail d'un mur un
sénateur du nebraska républicain s'est
fait attraper leur teint un coup de
téléphone avec ses électeurs
il a été vigilant et d'autres personnes
de ce qu'on appelle des vidéos des
républicains en ont seulement essayent
de plaire à leurs électeurs
ils veulent garder leur siège ils
veulent rester au poste ce genre de
personne ne fait qu'essayer de courtiser
les personnes des deux côtés dans les
deux parties mais je ne pense pas que
cela va nous mener à de bons résultats
pour ces personnes alors il ya aussi ces
rumeurs qui font état de certains
membres du parti républicain qui
souhaiteraient une victoire de joe biden
à la présidentielle tout en gardant la
majorité républicaine au sénat est ce
que cela vous semble plausible
la majorité républicaine au sénat est
très forte et l'une des fonctions les
plus importantes du sénat c'est de nous
mais était jochen des juges de la cour
suprême par exemple c'était un sujet
très important en ce moment je pense que
les républicains vont garder le sénat
mais personne qui reste fidèle à la
politique de donald trump ont beaucoup
plus de chances de remporter leur siège
que les autres d'un coup je pense que la
majorité va rester conservatrice au
sénat et je pense même que les
conservateurs ont vont reporter la
chambre des représentants donc nous
aurons ces trois institutions si donald
trump remporté les élections et cela
voudrait dire beaucoup de bien pour le
peuple américain
merci à vous aux jo dougherty je
rappelle que vous êtes un soutien de
donald trump